this video is brought to you by blinkers
the first 100 people to go to blinkers
calm Allwood / biographic s-- will get
one week to try it out you'll also get
25% off if you want the full membership
and let's get into it being the second
born child in a royal family can be a
blessing in disguise nobody expects you
to rule so in a way you kind of off the
hook but sometimes history gets in the
way and unexpected events can bring you
into the limelight and put you on that
throne that crown may represent one of
the youngest smallest and most peaceful
Nations in Europe but that does not mean
that trouble will not get in your way
this is what happened to today's
protagonist one of the longest-serving
and most respected Royals of the 20th
century King Haakon the seventh of
Norway the voice of dignity against
traitors and invaders at the time of
King Hawkins birth Norway was part of a
union with Sweden it had an independent
cabinet of ministers and its own
Parliament's but the formal head of
state was the king of Norway and Sweden
called the forth from the house of
Bernadotte based in Stockholm
therefore Norway did not have a ruling
dynasty of its own the man who had
become king of Norway was actually a
Danish Prince born near Copenhagen on
the 3rd of August 1872 in charlatan
lands Palace he was the second son of
the Crown Prince Frederick and Crown
Princess Louise of Denmark at birth he
was christened as Christian Frederick
Karl George Valdemar axel known simply
as Karl by those with shortness of
breath his elder brother would also
become King in the future King Christian
the tenth of Denmark while growing up
Karl would knock time and time again on
Christians door asking him to build a
snowman do you wanna ride our bikes
around the halls not really these guys
were actually incredibly serious and
they received extensive private tuition
at the palace at the age of just 14
Prince Karl began his training as a
naval officer so not really any snowman
in sight he worked hard alongside the
other cadets him was not accorded any
special privilege God graduated seven
years later in 1893 with a rank of
sub-lieutenant of the Royal Danish Navy
'im was later promoted to first left
tenants with that Karl ticked one of the
boxes expected from a prince a military
career the second box was finding a
suitable match in other words meeting
and marrying a girl preferably from
another European ruling house at that
time you could not throw a stone into a
Royal Palace without hitting someone's
cousin due to the Titan network of
familiar relationships among rulers Carl
did not stray from the norm and in 1896
he married his cousin from the United
Kingdom she was princess mord's the
daughter of King Edward the seventh and
his Danish wife Queen Alexandra
Alexandra was the sister of Frederick
Carl's father if this is getting
confusing air you can feast your eyes
with the family tree of the royal houses
of Norway Denmark Sweden and the United
Kingdom so you can have fun tracing the
blood ties amongst them I will post a
link to that family tree in the
description below so you can take a
closer look but let's not forget about
Maude
she was born in London on the 26th of
November 1869 since her early years
Princess Maude attended regularly her
mother's family gatherings in Denmark it
was one of such occasions that she came
to know her cousin Carl their wedding
was celebrated in Buckingham Palace on
the 22nd of July 1896 in the princely
couple settled in Copenhagen the Carl
and Maude always kept strong ties with
the UK and in fact their son an only
child Prince Alexander was born at
Appleton house in Norfolk England this
happens on the 2nd of July in 1903
little did the young family know that
their lives were going to change
drastically in the next couple of years
[Music]
on the 7th of June 1905 the Norwegian
Parliament known as the Storting passed
a resolution to dissolve the union with
Sweden the dissolution between Norway
and Sweden was a momentous events which
was born from an apparently lesser
dispute conflicts over the question of a
separate Norwegian consular service
Norway and Sweden had their own cabinets
and Parliament's but shared a single
head of state King Oscar the seconds
the Norwegians always felt like the
lesser party in the Union in fact they
did not have their own foreign service
missions and were subordinate to Sweden
in all matters of foreign policy a new
sense of national identity was brewing
in Norway and the Storting adopted a
decision to establish an independent
Norwegian consular service for those not
familiar with the subtleties of
diplomacy's embassies maintain
relationships with the governments and
institutions of the host country while
consulates support citizens brought the
practical terms Norwegian expats and
tourists had to rely on Swedish
consulates king oscar ii refused to
sanction the Storting z' decision as a
result the Norwegian government resigned
the king did not succeed in appointing a
new government this crisis meant that
the union between the two Scandinavian
countries was no longer effective and
while that takes us to the 7th of June
1905 when the Storting Assembly
unilaterally voted for a dissolution of
the Union the Storting
extended an offer to king oscar ii to
appoint a prince from his own house of
Bernadotte as the new king of norway
this gesture of goodwill would have
relieved the tension now mounting
between the two nations king oscar
though formally declines this offer the
Storting needed another candidate an
early version of linkedin would have
tried to solve the issue via mass
mailing to thousands of unqualified
applicants but the Norwegian assembly
was more effective and turns to another
candidate much closer to home our
friends Prince Carl of Denmark he
clearly fitted the job description job
ID number one Norwegian King and head of
state the ideal candidate should fulfill
the following prerequisites b-mail
military officer preferably in the Navy
as they have the smartest uniforms
Scandinavian familiar with Norwegian
language and culture related to the
house of Bernadotte
for example via his mother Louise niece
of King Oscar the seconds have close
ties the most powerful nation on earth
Britain for example via marriage with a
British princess must have sired a son
to ensure succession have a clean
driver's license and good Excel and
PowerPoint skills are not essential but
welcomes and of course we make the last
two pup this offer was extended to Carl
in autumn of that year the Danish Prince
was not a power grabber and did great
consideration for the will of the people
he was well aware that the majority
party in the Storting the Liberals were
considering the idea of making Norway a
republic so he insisted that before
accepting the crown he should listen to
the opinion of the Norwegian people on
his proposal it was decided that a
referendum would be held to decide
Norway's future form of governments the
referendum was held on the 12th and 13th
of November 1905 the result was almost
two hundred and sixty thousand votes in
favour of a monarchy versus almost
seventy thousand for the Republic
this gave Prince Carl a clear popular
mandate on the 18th of November Carl
found in his inbox a telegram sent from
the presidents of the Storting formally
offering him the Norwegian throne Prince
Carl happily accepted the offer
announcing that he would change his name
to Hakan while his son Alexander would
be known at Olav due to his love of the
summer season the King's choice of name
was significance in Old Norse it
translates as high son or chosen son and
it had been used by Norwegian kings
centuries earlier when the country was
independence horn also adopted a
personal motto alt for Norge or all for
Norway now just before we get into the
application of their very motto let me
tell you a bit about today's sponsor who
make this video possible Linkous look
it's not always possible to sit down and
read or even listen to all of the books
that you would want I'm a pretty busy
dude so I understand that and I don't
read nearly as much as they used to or
as much as I would like to but the good
news is that I have an app on my phone
called bling
which you can download and then
basically it provides 15-minute
summaries of all the best non-fiction
books so and by the way you could either
read these summaries in about 15 minutes
or you can listen to them as well
something I've discovered I always
exclusively listen just stop my way to
and from where come on I'm tottering
around the house and things like that
something I've recently discovered
funnily enough is that discovery section
and they've got these things called
curated lists where you can open up and
they've got ok so here's one flow the
ultimate state of minds and in it
they've got nine titles that they
recommend the top one unsurprisingly is
this book called deep work by Cal
Newport which I have read I think I read
it last year maybe the year before when
did it come out like 2016 and this one
you can like let me just see if I can
play a lot of segments for you
in between the two tasks Laroy would
give a quick test so yeah you've got
like this 15 minute summary of the book
I've read this book so I find it
fantastic because I mostly forgotten
what it's about that I can go in and get
this summer and it reminds me of the
rest of the bird but it's not really
necessary to do that if you just want
the best stuff from one you grab it in
there that is bullying kissed there are
tons of books so whatever you're into
you're gonna find something you like now
the first hundred people to go to
blinkers calm /by graphics will get a
week to try it out and you'll also get
25% off the full membership again that's
a 7-day free trial you can cancel at any
time of Linkous calm /ba graphics a link
below let's get back to our story
[Music]
on the 25th of November 1905 Norway's
new royal family sailed into the capital
Kristiania later Oslo on the naval
vessel Heimdall named after the guardian
God of Norse mythology Prime Minister
Nicholson welcomes the king with these
words it has been nearly 600 years since
the Norwegian people have had a king of
their own not in all this time has he
been solely our own we have always had
to share him with others chosen by a
free people as a free man to lead this
country he is to be our very own once
again the king of the Norwegian people
will emerge as a powerful unifying
symbol of the new independent Norway and
all that it shall undertake I really
love it if this speech was followed by
Knights chancing the king of the north
the king of the north well that didn't
happen remember these are serious guys
the speech was followed by a salvo of
cannons which is still cool and church
bells ringing throughout Oslo on the
27th King Haakon swore an oath of
allegiance to the Constitution on the
22nd of June 1906 King Haakon and Queen
Maud were crowns in need Arras Cathedral
in Trondheim once again Holcomb showed
himself to be a king of the people well
aware that the custom of coronation was
considered to be archaic and
undemocratic by many citizens they opted
for a subdued ceremony for instance the
traditional lavish procession previously
staged by the Bernard Oates was
eliminated the king and queen were
escorted to the cathedral in a single
coach drawn by four horses the travel
itself to Trondheim was conducted with
little ceremony by train and carriages
with many stops along the way so that
Hawken and morg could get acquainted
with the people of their new country
once they arrived at the cathedral they
were welcomed by 2,300 attendees and by
the two bishops who were to perform the
ceremony Bishop axelsson of nayara
stands the wonderfully named bishop bang
of Oslo and yes that was his real
surname you can look it up if you want
to bishop bang greeted the king with the
words may the Lord bless you're going in
and you're going out now and forevermore
very appropriate of a bishop bang I'm
just gonna stop there though before I
get sent to hell immediately after the
coronation King Haakon immersed himself
in Norwegian politics and culture polar
explorer Fridtjof Nansen introduced the
royal
to the national sport skiing King Haakon
also started new traditions such as the
much-loved
annual children's parade but besides
these rare popular celebrations Ian Moir
showed great moderation especially in
comparison with the other royal families
of the time the royal court was small
and expenses they were kept to a minimum
this was yet another sign of Hawkins
political sensibilities while aware that
more than 20% of the nation had
Republican sympathies he felt it
important to maintain a modest lifestyle
this moderation was also in line with
Norwegian tradition and respected the
fact that Norway was not a wealthy
country at that time today the country
is the eighth largest producer of all
worldwide and the third largest producer
of gas but the first shillings they were
still decades away King Haakon was also
wary of respecting the Norwegian
Constitution to which he had sworn an
oath of allegiance he firmly believed
that political power should be in the
hands of democratically elected
representatives but he still wished to
be kept closely informed about political
affairs by the government although he
might state his views on a certain case
he always deferred to the majority in
the Council of State unfailingly
supporting policy decisions and it was
also careful never to show an affinity
for any political party during his first
years on the throne Alcon oversaw
important reforms such as the
institution of universal female suffrage
in 1913 but a more testing ordeal was
just around the corner and that was of
course World War 1 in the years
preceding World War one hawkins foreign
minister yun Loveland's outlines
norwegian foreign policy along two
directives neutrality in combination
with an active trade policy neutrality
issued political alliances that might
drag the country into foreign wars with
the implicit agreements that norway was
within the British sphere of influence
the government expected the British
Empire to defends the young country in
any case of foreign aggression when
Germany declared war on Russia on August
the 1st Norway along with Sweden and
Denmark issued a declaration of
neutrality the next priority for the
country was to provide supplies feed the
population and maintain economic
stability this led to a difficult
balancing act for the Norwegian
government
the one hand trade with Germany was
vital for the country's economy on the
other hands the UK pressured Norway to
become part of the economic blockade of
Germany in the spring and summer of 1915
Germany it started to buy huge
quantities of one particular supply from
Norway that's fish it was tons of fish
any fish related item they could get
ahold of in fact the result mothers
hardly any fish left for the Norwegians
called was out of stock salmon was out
of stock haddock was out of stock fish
stock was out of stock what little fish
was available was incredibly expensive
in an attempt to quell exports to
Germany Britain decided that they would
buy Norwegian fish instead this decision
decreased even more the availability and
affordability of a vital food supply
while flooding Britain with stocks of
Norwegian stock fish an autumn of 1916
life was dive in origins to continue
with the fishing theme they were caught
between a rock and a hard place on one
side the German Navy had extended their
unrestricted submarine warfare to the
Arctic sea sinking several Norwegian
merchant ships trading with Russia on
the other hand Great Britain had imposed
Bargo on coal imports as leverage to
prevents Norway from selling copper ore
to Germany Hawken and Maud they were not
oblivious to the plight of their people
in addition to conducting an even more
frugal lifestyle the royal couple
established a fund to assist citizens
and extremely difficult circumstances
luckily for the country the Norwegian
and British governments reached a deal
the tonnage agreements in February of
1917 this was a very clever set up first
Britain would lift the coal embargo in
exchange Norway would suspend trade with
Germany and supply the on Taunton stet
the Norwegian merchant ships with
travelling convoys protected by the
Royal Navy reducing the risk of sinking
by the Kaiser submarines the clever bit
was that the agreement was signed by the
Norwegian ship owners association which
camouflaged the Norwegian government's
involvement allowing them to preserve a
formal neutrality hence Norway became
known as the neutral Ally the positive
effects of this Agreement though did not
reach all levels of society immediately
in June 1917 ordinary citizens were
still struggling to cope with a cost of
living that had increased by 250 percent
since the start of the war over 300,000
people
took to the streets in June to
demonstrate against a lack of food and
the money to pay for necessities
that's roughly 1/7 of the overall
population the government did not fall
although this crisis led to a
radicalization of the Labour Party whose
members even considered revolution as an
answer
[Music]
luckily for hawk on the revolution did
not take place rather an evolution of
the electoral system happens in 1919
which ensured a fairer representation of
the working-class years later in 1927
this reform led to the Labour Party
winning the majority at the Storting in
1928 Horan resisted pressures two former
government's led by the Conservative
agrarian party and respected Labour's
majority by appointing its leader
Christopher horns read as Prime Minister
the Conservatives were not happy about
the decision but it would take only
three years for the agrarian party to
return to power among their ranks a
former military attache now defense
minister became very active in using the
Armed Forces to quell Union strikes and
keep the specter of Bolshevism at bay
his name was Vidkun Quisling and it's at
this point that I'd ask you to check out
our video about him he was a Nazi
collaborator became the definition of a
traitor and was the man who welcomes an
invasion so he could be Prime Minister
but here's a quick summary former
Defence Minister crystalling founded the
National Union party in May of 1933
modeling it after the Nazi and fascist
parties defeated in two consecutive
elections crystalling forged a
friendship with hitler's advisor Alfred
Rosenberg and Exploited these ties to
facilitate the German occupation of
Norway but during the 1930s these
schemes had not yet to become a source
of war ether King Haakon
who had to face more personal issues on
the 20th of November 1938 his beloved
Queen Maud died in London after a
prolonged illness while visiting her
British relatives Maud was buried in the
royal mausoleum at Akasha scarce all
apparently shy in public Maud was known
for being warm and vivacious with family
and friends
her original personality set her apart
from other Queens of the time she
enjoyed outdoor activities like riding
and skiing more than court protocol and
was a keen dancer and a competent
photographer she was also direct
in Prince Olaf's upbringing Hawken would
surely have loved to have been by her
side during his and her country's
darkest hour the German invasion of
April 1940 in our crystalling video we
cover in detail the invasion of Norway
the country's resistance efforts and its
eventual liberation today I'll talk
about the same events but from Hawkins
perspective an occupation of Norway was
part of the Third Reich strategies the
country could provide the German war
effort with iron ore and an extensive
Merchant Navy it would have happened
regardless of crystalling scheming to
facilitate the German invasion when he
was hoping to be installed as Prime
Minister German troops invaded Norway on
the 9th of April 1940 the heavy cruiser
blue shirt sailed into the Oslo force in
the early morning hours of that day
transporting a landing force their task
was to arrest the King and the members
of the government to compel Norway to
capitulate immediately but the
Norwegians they were no pushovers the
Ford was protected by the cannons of the
Oscars Borg fortress as well as torpedo
batteries they all opens fire on the
blue sure and she sank at 6:22 a.m. with
1300 sailors on board the sinking of
this ship delayed the German troops
advance on Oslo giving the royal family
the government's and the Storting
representatives the time needed to
escape to safety and Alvar AM in eastern
Norway there the Storting gave the king
and the government full authority to
rule the country for the duration of the
war on the same day Crown Prince Olav
ensured the safety of his family by
having his wife Martha and their three
children crossed the border to Sweden
they then traveled to the United States
in August
thanks to Martha's friendship with
Franklin Eleanor Roosevelt she became
the sort of unofficial Norwegian
ambassador in Washington on the 10th of
April King Holcomb met with the German
envoi Kurt brah the germans demanded
that the government stepped down the
king had to appoint a new government
headed by Vidkun Quisling the King got
forward the German demands in an
extraordinary meeting of the Council of
State in the village of Nyberg Hans
Hawkins stated that he would not attempt
to influence the decision of the
government in this matter but that he
could not comply with the German
ultimatum he would rather abdicate than
have crystalling as Prime Minister
without directly imposing as well the
king had managed to influence the
decision of his Minnis
into rejecting crystalling upon hearing
of the king's refusal German forces
repeatedly bombs the village but he and
Olaf managed to escape to safety on the
fifteenth of April the first allied
landing party had arrived in Nava --q
the combined Anglo French polish force
would support the norwegian army and
engaging the german troops that the
Allies were ill-prepared for mountain
warfare and the Luftwaffe had complete
air superiority by the end of May the
British Cabinet had decided for a total
retreat to avoid losing the
expeditionary force to the Germans King
Haakon was left with a difficult choice
fleeing or staying staying by his people
would have seemed natural but the
Germans were not hiding their intentions
to have him captured he could have then
been forced to ride legitimacy to Chris
Lang's government in the end he decided
to flee the country they would establish
a government in exile in London from
where he could denounce crystalling or
any other collaborationist cabinets and
lead the resistance effort on the 7th of
June 1940 the king the Crown Prince and
the government travelled to England on
the 9th Norway had surrendered the
Norwegians and their allies they held
out for two months against a German
invasion longer than any other country
except for the Soviet Union like I said
there were no pushovers from London King
Auckland became the foremost symbol of
the Norwegian people's will to fight
free and independent Norway his radio
broadcasts from London they served as a
source of inspiration for young and old
alike back in Norway the Germans have
realized that crystalling was an
unreliable leader with little popular
support the reins of the country were
effectively taken by Reich's
Commissioner Yosef turban he attempted
to establish legal occupation government
selected by the Storting to collaborate
with the Nazis but this required the
Kings abdication in a speech on the 8th
of July 1940 Hawken again made it clear
that he would not give in to german
demands and that he was still the
legitimate head of the norwegian state
on the 25th of September turban
abandoned all plans to collaborate with
the existing Norwegian authorities he
declared the king and government deposed
and outlawed all political parties
except for quislings National Union all
activities in support of the raw family
were forbidden but King Haakon and the
government in exile stood firm in their
resolve to fight until Norway was
liberated over the next five years
hawkins speech
would inspire daily constant acts of
civil disobedience against the German
occupiers Hawkins monogram may 7 imposed
on a capital H became a symbol of
defiance
Hawken also inspired the creation of the
log or homefront this resistance
movement was a constant thorn in the
Nazi side it worked closely with the
Special Operations Executive and was
responsible for the destruction of the
Telemark plants which stalled the German
research on the atomic bomb by the end
of the war Norway was garrisoned by
approximately 400,000 German troops one
soldier for every six citizens this
gives an indication of how difficult it
was for the Reich to tame the Norwegians
again like I said no pushovers
[Music]
Germany capitulated on May the 8th 1945
Turban committed suicide on the same day
while Quisling was trialed and executed
in october King Horan returned home on
the 7th of June the fifth anniversary of
his escape to London in late summer 1945
he embarked on a tour of the country to
see for himself the destruction caused
by the war as well as to encourage the
ongoing efforts to rebuild
infrastructure the Norwegians were happy
to have their King back and grateful for
his resolve during the ordeal of the war
a collection was launched to raise funds
for a special 75th birthday present a
royal yacht king Holcomb accepted this
gift in 1947 and rechristened the vessel
the gnorga which he used in many
official visits brought Vulcan continued
to maintain strong ties with the UK even
after Ward's death during one of his
visits to London he attended a
theatrical performance of the moon is
down by John Steinbeck the original
novel was published in 1942 as a means
to encourage resistance in Nazi occupied
countries and its setting
characteristics and plot were based on
the invasion of Norway one of the
protagonists is the elderly calm
authoritative mayor Auden who encourages
his citizens to disobedience and open
rebellion against the invaders it is not
difficult to find Hawkins influence on
this character and on his opposition to
the treasonous shopkeeper choral
crystalling in disguise after 52 years
on the throne aged 85 King Hawke on the
seventh died at the royal palace in Oslo
on the 21st of September 1957 and was
buried at mort's side in the Royal
mausoleum at a Catrice cárcel so I
really hope you enjoyed today's by
graphics as a final thought I will leave
you with Hawkins dilemma would you have
stayed in Norway by your people and risk
giving legitimacy even
involuntarily to Kris Ling and turban or
what do you flee the country like he did
and a little quiz for you can you name a
European royal who decided to stay after
the German invasion
well post your answers and your opinion
in the comments section below also
please do check it off fantastic sponsor
blinkers a link below
and I'll see you next time
[Music]